the best YouTubers in the world starting
with Mr Beast Down spend more time and
more money on their thumbnail than you
could ever imagine so number one for
everybody who's going to do video and
again that's a whole another
conversation because for some people it
should be written word some people
should be doing audio some people should
be doing video I think the thumbnail on
video is incredibly important I think
the first 3 seconds do we need the hook
from the thumbnail to be delivered on in
the first 2 or 3 or 4 seconds we really
believe we do if my hook says 30 to 40
year olds you should be thinking about
LinkedIn and if my opening line is like
before we get into that in two seconds
you may lose that audience one thing
that continues to work for me is taking
headlines that are happening in pop
culture business and doing a green
screen and talking over it that model
continues to work better than if I just
looked in camera right now and talked
about it attention is the number one
asset so the first thing I want to ask
you is what would you do today you know
in today's world you know inflation and
everything that's going on in the world
it's really crazy right now yes if you
were to build a business today what
would you do differently I don't know if
I would do anything differently and more
importantly back to Bringing as much
value to the audience as possible I
think the thing I think most about is am
I putting myself in a position to
succeed and will this work and I think
if you ask those questions one of the
biggest things that everyone who's
listening needs to think about is do I
like this am I good at it like why am I
I doing this am I doing you know real
estate because my other friends say you
can make money in real estate am I doing
cannabis or crypto or something else CU
it seems like it's hot am I doing um
social media influencer because that
seems easy to me the reason I don't
think about things differently there's a
million things I can do differently on
everything I do V friends Vayner X Wine
Library Gary vbr the books
but I don't think about it from the
small little things I think about it
from the big things and I think most
people get the big thing wrong they
don't put themselves in a pos position
to succeed they either are delusional
and think they're better at something
than they are yeah which I understand
like we all want to hope and dream and
it's okay to go for it but I do think
that too many people struggle with
self-awareness and I do think that
building something meaningful meaning
living life on your own two feet and not
working for someone which means it's a
constant pressure it's all on you I do
think it requires you enjoying it yes if
you're going to do it long term because
in the hard
days the fact that you wake up and still
want to do it CU you like it helps a lot
and when you're just doing it for the
money you're going to give up more often
than not and so that's how I think about
it yeah totally agree with you how how
did you figure out out for example your
why that you know besides the whole
story the Jets the family but how did
you figure out what your why was so that
it wasn't just for money it was so early
for me that's why it's so hard for you
know and you know this I know we've been
on this journey and you know a lot of my
stuff it's hard for me to talk about
find I don't talk about finding why a
lot no no you don't I really don't yeah
I really don't it's because I don't
think I have a great point of view on it
because for me it was so natural you
know it was so early I mean I genuinely
don't remember a time where I didn't
want to be a businessman you know and so
for me it it came very early but I do
talk about tasting different things I do
talk a lot about taking advantage of
your 20s and 30s you know I do talk
about even in your 40s 50s 60s 70s
understanding it's not quote unquote
over
that there is opportunities but I I
think one thing that I think you have a
this is a strength of yours if I could
watch it from afar I think people say no
too much and don't say maybe enough yeah
and I think I I been becoming more and
more passionate about the concept of
maybe you know I'm in maybe all the time
most things become no but many things do
become yes and I do think that that's
something that people need to think
about yes you know like uh Ai No that's
going to be bad it's going to take jobs
without ever spending 10 hours of
research uh the blockchain no especially
now oh nfts were B no no do you actually
understand or or Tik Tock well I missed
it it's too late well actually it's not
the way Tik tok's built is it's based on
the individual post and starting
tomorrow is just as viable as starting
two years ago and so I I think that
people say no and so I think for the
people listening trying to find their
why if it didn't come natural to you
there's people that wake up and at 6
years old they want to be a stay-at-home
mother or father at 6 years old they
want to be a teacher at 6 years old they
want to be a firefighter at 6 years old
they want to be a doctor at 6 years old
they want to be an entrepreneur but for
a lot of people it's not that easy it
doesn't come that natural and I do think
that people need to keep pushing
themselves take a pottery class you know
like
you know go uh you know go to a concert
of a different style of music people
don't make themselves uncomfortable or
they're not curious enough or they're
not willing to you know try out of fear
and I think about that a lot yeah yeah
totally now when it comes to to social
media you just mentioned uh Tik Tok for
you today what would be the top three
platforms to be on because there are so
many and what would you do on each of
them if if you were starting now what
would would you do on Tik Tok YouTube
Instagram or Facebook yeah so I think
again back to the earlier point of
self-awareness if you're selling B be
all of a sudden LinkedIn is number one
right if you're selling if you're a SAS
if you started a SAS business if you're
listening right now and you want to or
you you sell to lawyers you have a
service that sells to lawyers then
LinkedIn is going to be number one
globally for sure with YouTube shorts
probably being number two because
YouTube is a search engine yes a lot of
people search there so that would also
be good if you were into SAS and then
probably in that scenario I would then
say if you're selling you know a B2B
service after those two probably
Facebook grounded in a Facebook group
with then Twitter X being probably
fourth if you're selling SAS Instagram's
probably a distant fifth Snapchat
Pinterest they super far away in that
scenario if you're selling T-shirts to
15 to 25 year olds all of a sudden Tik
Tok becomes number one instagram
probably becomes number two in that's SC
area and YouTube shorts is number three
right so I think for a lot of people
that's that reality for broader markets
I think that if you're really trying to
sell something like to the broad
consumer call it for everybody who's 25
to
55 well now you start getting into
Facebook still being an incredibly
powerful platform for selling mhm um I
do think that organic Tik Tok for
Branding is exciting Instagram again
becomes a stronger selling platform but
both of those scenarios require ads more
than organic
reach um whereas Tik Tok you can win on
organic reach and kind of capture
lightning in a bottle so the you know I
hope everybody appreciates the answer it
it it is
contextual but I think as far as the
answer to what you would would do inside
of it obviously there's a lot of Science
and Math of what time do you post how
long is the copy I think a couple things
to look out for number one the best
YouTubers in the world starting with Mr
Beast Down spend more time and more
money on their thumbnail than you could
ever imagine so number one for everybody
who's going to do video and again that's
a whole another conversation because for
some people it should be written word so
some people should be doing audio some
people should be doing video but I think
uh I think the thumbnail on video is
incredibly important I think the first 3
seconds thing that Dustin and I were
talking about on our trip this week is
do we need the hook from the from the
thumbnail to be delivered on in the
first two or three or four seconds and
and we we really believe we do we
believe that if if my hook says you know
30 to 40 year olds you should be
thinking about LinkedIn and if my
opening line is like before we get into
that I you know like you might in two
seconds you may lose that audience and
so I think a lot of science around the
art I think a couple of other things
there's a lot of ways to do it let me
encourage some people one thing that
I've been noticing is on Instagram you
could just take a photo of something
right you were here with your friend
this weekend in New York you could take
a photo of like a nice picture that
caught your eye in New York take a photo
but if you then wrote three paragraphs
really great ones because you're a great
writer about the concept of
enjoying the weekends to reset of the
concept of busyness and Chaos in
Controlled Chaos is an effective way to
be an
entrepreneur you could write the you
know curiosity I've been to New York
seven times but I've never gone down
this street right like you could take a
photo of anything a banana a car a tree
a bird your backyard it you really could
take a photo of almost anything and and
then write three or four paragraphs that
are very thoughtful about a point you're
trying to make now all of a sudden you
don't need a video and editing
team you could do it all by yourself and
for a lot of people listening they're
not great on camera they're not great
with their words but they're incredible
writers and so it's around
self-awareness of the me the the style
the content and then there's strategy
around the distribution depending on
your business and so that's one main
to keep getting very nerdy and deep on
your question the other thing to always
look for is underpriced attention the
thing that I know you know about me over
these last seven eight years is that I
have a very strong skill set in
understanding where there's more organic
reach against
consumption and and when to do it hard
than most people and that's been a big
part of My Success you were there when I
was yelling about musically and Tik Tok
when that when that seemed crazy to
almost everyone you you weren't there
but people that have been following me
all the way back to 2005 6 and seven
there was an incredible amount of
content and passion I had around YouTube
and Twitter and Facebook I mean I wrote
Crush in 2008 came out in 09 but I wrote
it in 2008 that's 15 years ago long time
so I I think that I constantly look for
the underpriced
attention it's always most exciting when
it comes up in a new platform but new
platforms only come around every 3 four
seven nine years yeah then when it's not
a platform it goes into the things we
just talked about the strategy within
the platforms I talked about recently
it's already lost momentum in a month
but a month ago I was incredibly excited
about posting a meme and then a video on
Instagram a two poost Carousel I saw
that M and you know I I I see incredible
uh opportunity that again almost talking
to Dustin I'm almost having my own
meeting right now one thing that
continues to work for me is taking
headlines that are happening in pop
culture business and doing a green
screen and talking over it that model
continues to work better than if I just
looked in camera right now and talked
and even when the the green screen the
the Green Screen Video is not great
quality like it doesn't look good but it
it works correct to your point my last
one which did really well I was in the
car and the light was hitting a
different way and it wasn't like my yeah
I was like distorted that's right but I
think I think that that's
um I think a great strength of mind that
I would encourage people to consider is
constantly trying new formats you know
uh I'll use you as an example we've
talked in the past whether on DM or
Twitter or in a V friend's Discord or
like this about like m i I'd like to get
more traction I want more views on my
videos and something that I don't think
I've given good advice on in the past to
you or the hundreds of thousands of
people that have asked me is look if you
have the same exact format format not
you're talking about different things
but it's camera to face and you post it
as an Instagram real and you're doing
that 50 100 times and you're not getting
really the results you want after a 100
times you've got to change it you've got
to change your format maybe you bring on
a guest maybe you go to green screen
maybe you go to written word and picture
I think you know I always think about
that concept of like you know the
definition of insanity is like doing the
same thing over and over and and
thinking you'll have a different outcome
so I do think I want to give permission
to a lot of people out there like if
you've done a 100 I think that's the
right thing if you've done a hundred of
the same format per se and you're really
really getting nowhere and you're now 6
months in you you know you should
challenge yourself to try different
formats yeah not talk about something
different just talk about the same thing
in a different in a different you know
like look I believe in 40 to 50 core
things and then I layer what's happening
in the world at the time yeah and new in
different formats and platforms and I
think um there's something there there
MH that's that's good advice I'm going
to try that because I love doing reals
like I love doing the video and some
work some don't and then something that
works on Instagram then I put it on Tik
Tok it doesn't work over there yeah Tik
tok's a whole different animal hard it
yeah it's hard it is hard but I think
you know I remind people like yourself
myself I say this to myself all the time
if you're looking for something special
to happen it's supposed to be hard yeah
you know yeah like I I I hear you know
right like even right yeah it's supposed
to be hard yeah like I was in this uh I
was where was I oh I was Friday night I
was in um in a airport lounge in Dallas
and this gentleman like a 60y old guy
you know he's a real yappy guy I was
trying to get a little work done before
my like to LA but he wanted to talk and
I'm about that life he had no clue who I
was or anything like that nature we were
just talking and he um he got into
something and he was like it's it really
seemed to me that this was a gentleman
and I confirmed some of this through the
conversation you know really really came
from rural America really like came from
nothing nothing and made a life of
himself and you know it was really nice
and his son was getting married in
Tennessee in a couple weeks really
enjoyed the conversation but he kind of
talked about you know uh how hard he
worked and then he was talking about
what was hard for him now and I kind of
had this fun moment where I was like Hey
brother like youve all people know like
you didn't get to this point by accident
you don't have to do the next thing but
it's not going to happen without hard
work and so I think you know yeah I
think people ask to be known to get
compensated for being themselves
to sell books to speak to sell things it
should be hard because 99% of the world
works for someone
else yep you've said it yep um so you
answered the next question I had so I'm
going to move on to the next one which
is I wanted to ask about be friends of
course um I see you're doing so much
like it's hard for me to keep up like I
miss like the plushies like I miss the H
thing well the Masters of the Universe
yes um I call it He-Man too by the way
yeah everyone does called he- but yeah
everyone called it He-Man Master
Universe very good um so I asked you
know I asked in the beer disc oops to my
fellow specs and and they asked me hey
can you ask G what does he have in store
for the future like after vcon 24 what's
going to happen or what do you have
planned for the nfts yes um especially
series one holders yeah so you know for
me the entire
vriends game launched you know game
meaning uh operations and building out
of V friends is predicated on people
falling in love with the characters
there is nothing else y you know like if
back to He-Man yeah right that Skeletor
thing that we did wouldn't have been a
big to-do if the world didn't love
Skeletor of course so you know I think
I'm empathetic when spec holders or
series 1 holders or any holders ask
what's going on with the nft I think
what I'm doing is creating the nft the
fact that I can speak to multiple people
who in the last two weeks watched
Fanatics live where we open up trading
cards yeah for hours at a time of
entertainment and
education they they they discover who
genuine giraffe ish and the fact that
there are multiple people who have gone
from not even knowing what V friends or
I was yeah discovering Us in the
Fanatics app in Discovery watching me
rips and con man Connor
uh you know hang out get interested and
excited by the community get educated
buy a pack for the next show get the
pack start to get on Twitter and meet
all of you go and buy a series 2 vriend
and then go and buy a series 1 V friend
nft all in two weeks and there's two or
three examples already yeah I was going
to ask have you tracked some of oh yeah
we track all of that and so the Skeletor
thing getting into the Masters so look I
I think what's really fun about nfts as
a collectible is you can do things
forever MH you see what wallets have it
things of that nature to your point
October has been a very big month we're
really trying to lean into the character
development of the Halloween characters
we think Halloween is a very big
platform for vriends but I think between
the Skeletor the plushies the mini and
vending machines the coffee
collaboration with Gregor's the Fanatics
live trading cards
uh obviously the announcement of vcon
2024 in Los Angeles you know I think
Beyond 2024 is what 2023 has been about
between burn Island background scenes
we're working during this Rec correction
down Market of the NF thing that's
beyond your control of course and we
anticipated it you know as you know I
made 30 40 different videos during and
interviews during August 2020 the height
yeah saying 95 97 99 of this is going to
zero um because because that's how that
these kind of things go you know nfts
are like trading cards they're like art
they're like sneakers they're like
watches they're going to be collectible
99% of watches are not collectible 99%
of sneakers are not collectible 99% of
trading cards are not Michael Jordan's
rookie card 99 of intellectual
properties are not He-Man Masters
universe or Disney or or Pokemon so you
know for your friends in those
communities um and for everybody broader
and for people who are listening that
are not into be friends but are
following other projects you know I
think the requirement of those projects
so I'll give you some Alpha in a little
more detail that people in the Discord
have heard in the past we are announcing
the kids book pretty soon here and it
will be in kids hands in 2024 you know
God forbid my first kids book just so
everybody knows when I wrote crush it
nobody knew who I was yeah you know what
I mean and that book went and so if
we're lucky enough to have this book go
and so we're working very heavily on
that we're working very heavily on
getting the animation infrastructure and
then as far as how I think about
specs Collectibles the way Collectibles
actually work is if you are fortunate
enough to get people to care about the
characters
overall Spider-Man number one's first
appearance or Spider-Man's Amazing
Stories you know if Spider-Man's first
appearance or Wolverine's first
appearance is more valuable than his
second or in trading cards there are
Kobe Bryant and LeBron James rookie
cards that are more rare than the
standard one right and they are more
sought after you know if I'm right and
if we're capable as a digital
collectible the specs have a
disproportionate world and you could see
that happening with what's happening
with trading cards if you go and look at
trading cards right now M on eBay yes
the to 25 epic of any character if we
were to go right now is dramatically
more valuable is it than the core what
has not happened yet is digital
Collectibles are so early that the
people are still trying to figure out
and so it takes time but you know to
answer your question very detailed and a
little bit more um long-winded for
example right here we're looking now
everybody who's listening the Whimsical
wolf is $31 as a rare to 500 if we were
to find a yellow one which is the Bas in
here right if and I don't know if we'll
find one actually here we go real quick
because I just want you to see yes the
the regular wolf is1 1999 right there's
a there's a there's a there's a gap yes
between the trading card people
understand that in vriends nft Land
series 1 not all the way just
yet but then there's also the part of
you know what utilities and what things
happen and so I think yeah like what's
like one side is a collectible and then
from your end will you continue to let
of course of course but but as you know
and everybody knows there's also Clarity
that we're looking for from legislation
that we have to wait for and so you know
it's listen this is a a no question a
tricky time for operators and collectors
don't forget I I'm a major collector on
the other side of of world look at that
wall yeah and and just of nfts creature
world world of women Yuga stuff so you
know we're all kind of navigating it but
look I think the best thing I can say is
I hope that the last six weeks and I've
definitely gotten a lot of people
reaching out based on this has shown
people it's not like we're looking to
make pretend this chapter never existed
you know I think if you you know what I
mean like I'm very committed to this
we're going to do this and we're going
to do it for the rest of our lives and
I'm I'm enjoying it you know it's it's
not fun to have like tension and like
concern and I see everything I know I
know you you know you know this I see
everything I'm working yes you know he
uh He-Man took 19 months it really
mattered there's a lot of people in
Masters of the Universe Reddit
communities and community and and
discords that are like wait a minute be
friends this cool skilled skeleton is
selling more as an nft because so like
we're working on it I know you got a lot
more and we're going to run out of time
so go ahead yes of course um so I wanted
to ask you now about your next book in
our last interview a year ago you told
me the title of the book and now it
changed yeah exactly what can you share
yeah so what I told you at the time was
it was going to be jab jab jab left hook
because I knew that I was going to write
a very similar book to that 10 years ago
which is what I am writing with day
trading attention the difference is when
I started writing the book versus when I
had it figured out a year ago when we
spoke I realized this is a much more
complex book than jab jab jab right hook
jab jabry Hook was very simple to
understand give give give then ask in
your content here's some examples of
content dat trading attention is very
detailed to what you and I talked about
20 minutes ago okay it is probably my
most academic book okay you know there's
even a part of me that worries that it
could be a hair boring I'm not kidding
I'm being dead serious it's so detailed
in the magic of what I do and what
Vayner media does but I'm proud of that
I think I think we will jab jab jab
right hook besides crushit is the book I
get most talked to about how it changed
someone's life especially now in
marketing so many of the people that are
in companies that we work with when the
meetings over on Zoom they're like hey
Gary can I just say something I'm only
in marketing because I read jab jab jab
right hook in high school or college and
it's very flattering day trading
attention has a chance to be a Manifesto
of the next five years of what to do on
social media as a reference point people
go back to it of course things will
change and I'm and I speak to that in
the book a lot but it's a very beefy
book and I'm really proud of it when
when is it coming out I'd like to have
it come out next summer next summer
we're we're just wrapping up the and
it's ironic we just touched on both um
uh I the kids book and day trading
attention have the potential come out
close to each other and obviously I want
to give them a little bit of breathing
room from a promotional standpoint so
we're just working on that awesome
excited about both thank you now ai I
know you've been talking about it as
well I want to know how you're using it
which tools you're using it how you
recommend for entrepreneurs we're using
Ai and some re speecher and some audio
translating my voice into other
languages I'll still
Spanish and and and and fary and German
and French like I think every one of
your favorite creators will be speaking
every language perfectly synced lips no
subtitles in native tongue within the
next 24 to 36 months at scale so that's
going to be enormous mid Journey for
creative thinking you know just typing
in different visuals as I visualize
things especially for internal
presentations and decks um chat GB PT
for thinking or answering questions like
just I I like using it for Trends you
know uh for example I'll ask like hey uh
Chad gbt why are people wearing corduroy
hats right now in culture like those
kind of things so you know those kind of
those three really stand out um you know
I've unfortunately have been so busy
with vriends this summer prepping this
fall and winter and now I'm even busier
vriends for
2024 that I'll be transparent I feel a
little anxiety not really but I am
disappointed that I haven't been able to
go deeper in more tools cuz there's just
so many hours in the day yeah but you
know it's uh it's very clear what this
AI journey is going to be it's an
incredible infrastructure to our society
um and it will change a lot of things
yes are you worried about because you've
said it too and I'm worried myself um
the Deep fake after aspect of it what
are your thoughts on that it's why I'm a
don't worry Dustin I know we're in New
York City everybody there's always
sounds like this in the background we
have no idea is
um I am worried about it and I think
it's because people are headline readers
so I'm worried because people believe
everything I'm going to say something
pretty wild there's a part of
me that is curious
about what it looks like when people
believe nothing mhm so right now we
believe everything and we're headline
readers and I think it's causing damage
what happens in 10 years when we don't
believe in
anything we don't believe what you said
or what I said on video because we're
not sure if somebody else made it and
here's the full circle we have to go to
the
blockchain to see if you and I post it I
believe every piece of content I post in
the future at some point will be posted
first on the blockchain to prove
Providence and then we'll go on the
internet and so if you see me say
something that really upsets you you're
like this is not the Gary I know you're
going to be able to go and look and be
like oh thank God he didn't say that
somebody made him say that in deep fake
video wow I think that because remember
blockchains are not owned by Iran or
America or Russia or China this is the
power of the blockchain and so the
blockchain has an incred
incredible seat at the table for society
in the next 100 years and as we become
more digital and it is the only true
source of truth that can't be
manipulated you start thinking about a
very interesting
thing you know one of the great things
back to Collectibles empathy elephant
series 1 spec Diamond will never have a
counterfeit there's unlimited
counterfeit art sneakers watches and
trading cards or in New York alone oh my
my God on the streets you know what I
mean but real counterfeit forget about
the streets where it's just obvious
there have been people who've really
spent $ 500,000 $300,000 for a p fake
Pokemon and Michael Jordan rookie card
so I think you know I think we're so
early on this but I'm very excited about
what the blockchain does but yeah deep
fake is going to be challenging like
it's going to be tough in a year when or
two when people up with audiences like
myself will have to be on a daily or
weekly basis going on their social media
saying that is not a video I made that
is not true I did not say that word or I
did not you know discriminate against
those people or I did not make that
claim about business and it happened
already during nft summer yeah people
were using my images all over social
media claiming that I was bought this
you know you you were close to it they
would air drop me the token I've seen
that yeah and then they would be like
Gary B buys 10 of so I mean you know
people are always doing stuff
unfortunately remember this everyone if
you're if you're worried it's always
cops and robbers it's always cat and
mouse something gets invented the bad
guys try to do something the good guys
try to capture them the good guys try to
do something bad guys try to get around
it it's just one big circle so deep fake
will be used for bad but we've created
as humans the blockchain that can be
used for good absolutely I'm excited
about it yeah yeah so I'm worried but
optimistic that's that's one of your
main qualities I think so I think I'm a
practical Optimist I'm not delusional no
I'm not an outer space I'm an operator
I'm I'm a I'm a thinker but I I do
believe in us more than most people yeah
I really do that's a good thing um and I
wanted to ask about your time management
because I think it's incredible uh how
does Gary decide we talked about this
earlier saying no and maybe and all of
this what what gets a yes from Gary also
you know because I'm here right now did
I get this yes what is your criteria for
that a lot of it's intuition mhm and a
lot of it's the complete opposite like
requirement I think I I run on
requirement and intuition you know I
have a lot of responsibilities so we're
now because I was a little bit late this
morning we're a couple minutes over
there's a three there's a call going on
right now with be friends and a
collaborator that's very important yes
I'm 3 minutes late but I felt that
because I was a little bit late this
morning and you came all the way out
here that I didn't want to cut our time
short these arec that are happening
every second especially for someone as
busy as I am I have three full-time
admins I have two chief of staffs I you
know I think what I do well is I don't
let meetings run long I talk about that
a lot I know 1 hour meetings could be 30
30 minute meetings could be 15 I think I
put my money where my mouth is most
people don't hire three admins and so
they get the results of two admins or
one admin the biggest mistake I think a
lot of people make and don't forget I
did my own admin work for 10 years
course excuse me 200
1998 I I did my own admin for 13 years
so I understand what it's like when
people hear me they're like I can't
afford I'm like I know I did that for 13
years but there was a point where I
realized wait a minute it's not good for
me to be doing this this is a lot of
time I'm putting into this I'm getting
busier and so I think a lot of
entrepreneurs or Founders don't get
admins fast enough and then they don't
trust
admins that's a b one you know and so I
think they'd rather buy nice clothes or
take a trip or buy a nicer car or a
better laptop and they're not investing
in themselves and their time is very
important it's their biggest value I can
make more money but I can't make more
time and I think about that a lot yeah
that's well Gary thank you so much uh
it's been I had like a million more
question oh by the way to answer your
question why you because I like you oh
because we have a real relationship you
know we've seen each other a lot we've
interacted a lot that's the beauty of
the internet we've seen each other a lot
in the scheme of things
but none of the the probably the second
time on we wouldn't have seen each other
if we didn't continue the conversation
on Twitter yes right yes so I think
social media creates the gateway to real
relationships I agree and I like that
and I like people and I like you and uh
that's why we're here thank you I love
you I love you
back